- Le bâtiment est si vieux que
les cinq salles d'opération
ont dû être fermées à plusieurs
reprises. Souvent, la
climatisation faisait défaut.
Et l'an dernier, la présence
de chauves-souris avait forcé
l'arrêt des chirurgies.
- Le constat, on n'est pas
capable de maintenir les
activités dans ce bloc-là.
Et le rénover coûterait
beaucoup trop cher.
- Il a donc fallu construire
en 24 mois un tout nouveau
bloc opératoire, un partenariat
public-privé.
- Le partenaire privé,
actuellement, offre
l'environnement physique,
s'occupe également de l'hygiène
et la salubrité du lieu.
Et pour le reste, tout le reste
est assumé par le CIUSSS.
- L'entreprise qui a construit
le bâtiment loue l'espace
au secteur public, qui y fait
travailler son propre personnel.
Les corridors sont larges
et baignés de lumière naturelle.
On retrouve ici sept salles
de chirurgie, deux de plus
que dans l'ancien pavillon.
(propos indistincts)
Mélanie Morin, qui a subi
la première de deux opérations
dans l'ancien bâtiment vétuste,
est impressionnée.
- Oui, je te dirais qu'il y a une grosse différence. Ça paraît
que l'hôpital est un petit peu
plus âgé qu'ici. Euh...
ha! C'est vraiment
plus beau ici. C'est blanc.
- Et les patients comme Mélanie
ont accès à des salles
d'opération haut-de-gamme.
Le rétinologue Flavio Rezende
l'opère à nouveau, mais
cette fois, dans les nouvelles
installations. Elles permettront
au chirurgien d'enseigner
en direct à des collègues de l'étranger.
- On a bâti le réseau Internet, informatique, dans
le bloc opératoire pour pouvoir
faire des conférences à distance
"live" sur le Web, pour faire
de l'enseignement pendant
des chirurgies.
- Une bonne nouvelle pour
l'enseignement et le rayonnement
international de Maisonneuve-
Rosemont. Des installations
qui vont aussi permettre
d'attirer et de retenir
le personnel. Un défi majeur
dans l'est de Montréal.
- On a la meilleure structure
pour amener pas juste
des infirmières, mais des
nouvelles recrues. Tout...
tout le monde qu'on aimerait
engager, maintenant, ça devrait
être plus facile.
- Et effectivement, pour
une rare fois dans l'est
de Montréal, on rencontre
des infirmières comblées. Après
18 ans dans le vieux pavillon,
Sandra Tremblay est épatée.
- Bien, là, maintenant, c'est
concret. On est rendu dans nos
espaces. Et c'est vraiment wow!
- Vous avez l'air heureuse.
- Tellement!
- Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.